what I want to do in this video is find
the arc length of one petal I guess we
could call it of the graph of R is equal
to four sine of two theta so I want to
find the length of this portion of the
curve that is in red right over here and
we'll do this in two and I guess two
phases first of all I want to set up the
definite integral for finding in that
arc length and then we'll evaluate it
and I'll actually use a calculator to
evaluate it because it'll be a little
bit more straightforward at least for
this integral so let's just start with
that I encourage you to pause the video
and knowing what we know about the
formula for arc length when we have it
in polar form see if you can apply it to
figure out this arc length right over
here so I'm assuming you've had a go at
it so let's just remind ourselves that
the arc length is going to be the
integral from our starting angle to our
ending angles will call it from alpha to
beta of the square root of of the
derivative of our of our function with
respect to theta squared plus our
function squared plus our function
squared D theta so let's figure out what
our prime of theta and what R of theta
actually are so maybe I'll color code it
so our prime of theta our prime actually
well we know what R of theta is let me
just rewrite it so we know R of theta is
equal to 4 sine of 2 theta 2 theta so
our prime of theta our prime of theta is
just going to be derivative of 2 theta
with respect to theta is 2 times 4 is 8
derivative of sine is cosine cosine of 2
theta and so if we wanted to write the
the definite integral for arc length
it's going to be equal to so it's going
to be equal to the definite integral now
what's our starting bound well for the
petal that we care about we're going to
start at an angle of 0 radians
when we have an angle of zero radians R
is zero that's this point right over
here so we're going to start at zero
radians and we're going to go all the
way up to PI over two when sine of two
times pi over two is sine of Pi which is
zero so we're get back to this point
right over here so we're going to go
from zero to PI over two to PI over two
radians it's going to be the square root
of give myself some real estate here R
prime of theta squared it's going to be
this thing squared
so it's going to be 60 weird isn't that
same blue color so it's going to be 64
cosine squared of two theta and then
plus this squared which is going to be
16 sine squared of two theta and then of
course we have our D theta D theta and
you can attempt to solve this or
evaluate this analytically it's not too
straightforward so I'm going to use a
calculator and this gives us practice
with knowing that hey are there tools
out there that can help us do these
types of things so I'll go to the
definite integrals here I go to the
second calculus on my t 85 I pick this
choice which is for the definite
integral and so let me express what I'm
taking the definite integral of so it's
going to be the square root of 64 times
cosine of 2 theta squared so cosine and
I'm going to use X instead of theta just
because it's an easier variable to use
on my calculator so cosine of 2 cosine
actually let me make sure my parentheses
are good so I'm going to say cosine of 2
X cosine of 2 X all right now close that
and now I want to square that all right
I did that first part plus 16 plus 16
times 16 times sine sine of 2x close
that close that squared and actually I
already see let make it sure I'm not
sure if the calculator knows to
interpret that as multiplication so let
me insert a times right over here so 64
times cosine of 2x that thing squared
plus 16 times sine of 2x that thing
squared and now let me go to the end and
then that's and then let me close my
radical so that's going to close that
right over there or that closes what I'm
taking the square root of and then comma
the variable that I'm integrating with
respect to is X in this case everywhere
I saw theta here I'm just replacing with
an X there and I want to do it from
instead of theta equals 0 to theta
equals PI over 2 we'll say X is equal to
0 to X is equal to PI over 2 PI over 2
and hopefully I have not made a mistake
when I've typed this in and I get it's
chugging on it a little bit and we get
will it actually come up well finally
alright so if we were to round it let's
say it around it to the nearest
thousandth it'll be nine point six eight
eight so approximately nine point six
eight eight let's just see does that
does that make intuitive sense let's see
it goes about it goes as far as four
away so if you just went out to four and
then back down that would be about eight
but of course we have we've actually
gone out some so it actually makes
intuitive sense that this arc length
would be nine point six eight eight
anyway hopefully you enjoyed that